This is chaos magic wanda and
that makes you the scarlet witch
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
Wandavision finale top 10 predictions video
obviously there's so many plot lines that they
have to wrap up they need like a two hour finale
so there's no way that they're going to be able
to explain every single thing i'll explain that
during the video because they do have a plan for
how this sets off doctor strange 2 spider-man 3
no way home at all the new mcu mutants and x-men
characters they have coming up in the next several
years Wandavision is meant to be the tipping
off point for a bunch of different projects
if you're new to my channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes i'll be doing videos for
all of the marvel series this year on disney plus
falcon and winter soldier is just going to be the
next one loki will come after that then there's
a couple others coming later this year as well
careful for spoilers for all the Wandavision
episodes so far if you're not caught up
but starting with number 10 there will be a
family team up confirmed because of the pictures
they were dropping the past couple of days call
them the fantastic four incredibles the hex men
make all the jokes post all the memes
this scene is obviously taking place
after something happens between agatha harkness in
scarlet witch like they obviously have their big
gunslinger standoff moment in the streets at the
end of episode eight she has billy and tommy on
magical leashes like she's walking him around like
a couple of dogs but there were a whole bunch of
characters we did not see during episode eight so
you remember vision took off at the end of episode
seven to come back to their home he'll show up
pretty soon you have darcy that's on her way
too you have monica rambeau that just got caught
by evan peters character we learned that she's
probably resistant to act of the hardness's dark
magic so she'll be able to help out pretty soon
too but we don't know exactly what happened to her
at the end of the episode it just implied that she
got caught by evan peters so you have to imagine
that right after this moment after they have a
bit more of a standoff then everybody shows up
and that allows them to rally and have their big
family moment here where they all team up against
agatha harkness probably not going to go the way
you expect it to go but i think they kind of
set this concept up you have this family of
super powered people coming together it would be
weird if they didn't have a family team up moment
so number nine next big prediction there will
be a quicksilver time in a bottle style scene
but big twist it'll be tommy speed who gets
to do it remember they spent all of episode
six setting up the concept of their powers
and he has powers that look exactly like
and it just feels like a very kevin feige thing
to do like that's one of the coolest things about
that character that he did during the marvel x-men
films and he was such an underutilized character
during those x-men films why would they take all
this time to set up the idea that now scarlet
witch has a child who has those powers and not
give him some really cool really badass scene
during the final battle yes i am expecting them to
answer the question of evan peters character for
real like they'll finally explain exactly what's
going on with this character because they keep
raising more questions than they answer i believe
the reveal for his character will have something
to do with revealing who senior scratchy is who
the bunny is that she's been carrying around this
whole time but number eight next big prediction
is part of that billy wicken will also use his
powers during the big final battle he has the
exact same powers in the comics as scarlet witch
telekinesis psychic powers reading people's minds
and at least in the comics he also has reality
warping powers too although what Wandavision
has done as a tv show is just combine her chaos
magic abilities with reality warping saying that
it's the same thing they've explained that when
she's altering reality she's weaving a number
of complex spells simultaneously using cosmic
background radiation to power them sort of like
a backdoor infinity gauntlet move because the
background cosmic radiation is the same type of
energy that's given off by the infinity stones
they want to make her op but they don't want to
make her ridiculously op so it's not like she's
going to be able to recreate all the infinity
stones they'll probably have a couple ways of
explaining why that's not the case because if you
had a problem why wouldn't you just create another
set of infinity stones and it'd be a get out of
jail free card and they don't want too many of
those because those tend to break stories like why
would there be any stakes if you could just create
another infinity gauntlet on the spot so also
as part of that i'm also expecting that whatever
billy's powers in the finale are they'll just be
a slightly lower power version of what scarlet
witch's powers are like it won't be exactly the
same but pretty close number seven visions main
battle as they've been hyping up will probably
be against the white vision he's called project
cataract cataracts lead to bad vision aka evil
vision i know everyone's asking questions about
ultron easter eggs because all tyler hayward and
sword have done is just reassemble vision's body
and patch him a little and most of his base code
is based on ultron's code combined with jarvis's
code so if he doesn't have his personality or
his soul people are like would he be more like
ultron but just to clarify it'll still be paul
bettany playing the character but he'll probably
act just way more hardcore more like ultron but i
don't think that he'll literally speak as ultron
and just for reference white vision's powers are
basically the exact same as regular visions powers
sans the mind stone like he has that focusing
array at the top of his head instead of the
mind stone it's probably like a little mini
arc reactor and he gives off a blast like the
big energy beam just like regular vision does
with the mind stone in follow-up for vision's
character too per their conversation in the
flashbacks what is grief if not love persevering
i think that'll wind up being foreshadowing for a
downer vision ending where they are successful in
defeating and deactivating white vision but they
won't combine white vision with fake hex vision
like scarlet witch will have to say goodbye to
vision again she'll find the strength to finally
say goodbye and then move on with her life maybe
they'll even try to give him some sort of burial
or eulogize him in some way like she was trying
to do when she came to the sword base in the
flashbacks i just want to bury him i'm his next
of kin but they'll have a way of explaining why
someone can't just repair white vision and then
bring him back again later kevin feige said that
they're not actively developing Wandavision season
2 but never say never so potentially at some point
at a later date they could always try to do
it but they're not planning on it right now
number six next big prediction agatha harkness's
main ability through her purple looking dark
magic is basically feeding on other people's power
feeding on the magic from other witches we see her
consuming her coven's magic in the past it makes
her more powerful giving her a big upgrade enough
to defeat her own mother whose name we actually
learned in the credits is evanora harkness big
fans of wizard of oz will remember that that's the
name of the wicked witch of the east i guess in
that scenario doctor strange would be like the oz
the great and powerful but this whole time agatha
hartness has been pushing wanda to use her powers
more and more she gaslet vision into leaving the
hex barrier for the very purpose of getting wanda
to expand the hex more to use her chaos magic
again so per the foreshadowing in this flashback
scene she'll get wanda to do that again unload a
bunch of her magic to fight her properly drink it
up like a milkshake wanda's chaos magic milkshake
giving agatha another big power upgrade her whole
thing during episode 8 taking wanda back through
her memories was to finalize her theory on chaos
magic being the source of the hex she didn't quite
figure it out to that ending scene right there
like this is chaos magic wanda you're dangerous
the number five follow-up prediction once again
the hardness does get powered up by leeching
wanda's chaos magic that's when things really go
off the rails and we'll see more references to her
book of dark magic that they teased in episode
seven we'll probably find out who ralph is the
person who she keeps calling her husband but who
we've never seen on the show that we know of and
he'll wind up being someone far more powerful and
possibly the main villain of doctor strange 2 some
larger dark cosmic entity that she's connected to
through the use of her book in her brand of dark
magic when her mother was putting her on trial
on those flashbacks she made it sound like she
was playing with fire by trying to learn all this
really dangerous dark magic before she was ready
in the coven had very special rules about how and
when you were allowed to attempt certain kinds
of powerful magic she broke those rules out of
vandy like i can do anything i want i don't care
so that idea in combination with the extra power
up she gets from wanda's chaos magic will open
the doorway metaphorically and maybe literally to
the plot of doctor strange 2 in a bigger villain
we'll see whether or not there's an actual cameo
for that villain on the show agatha hardness is
supposed to be the main villain of Wandavision but
i think we all believe that she's connected to the
main villain of doctor strange 2 my current theory
right now is that it's going to be nightmare but
there are a couple of possibilities the number
four pretty easy prediction the big avengers
cameo in the finale will be benedict cumberbatch's
doctor strange just showing up to help wanda and
give her a big call to action like explain why
it is they need to team up for doctor strange 2
multiverse of madness like imagine him showing up
and just asking wanda what have you done with all
this act of the heartless hex and chaos magic
nonsense what you're doing has created these
dire consequences for the multiverse and then
that's the main reason doctor strange shows up
also to take agatha harkness's book into
safe keeping at the library and the sanctum
one of his big things is also keeping a watch
list of all the most dangerous people on planet
earth so ag of the harkness would probably be on
his list and because the book itself is probably
very dangerous he would want to get his hands on
that as well number three also we'll find out how
Wandavision sets up spider-man 3 no way home more
connections to doctor strange 2 as well because
doctor strange is showing up during spiderman no
way at home remember all the spiderman trailer and
preview images from a couple days ago there were
a ton of easter eggs in those but for example look
in these pictures in particular if you look at
the ground here it looks like they're standing
inside a version of the sanctum but it's all run
down everything's gone to it looks like it's been
abandoned for years and there's even snow on the
ground inside what looks like the main entryway
you see the pattern on the floor looks the exact
same as the pattern of the floor of the sanctum
in these other images here so either this is a big
misdirect like it's an enchantment on the sanctum
so that when normal people barge through the front
door the building looks condemned like no one's
lived here for years but it is possible that the
multiverse consequences that wanda enacted the
heartless cause with all the chaos magic lead to
the sanctum looking like this during spider-man 3.
but there's a number of different reasons why
they could be standing inside a version of the
sanctum that looks like crap so don't jump to
too many conclusions too fast before we get
the first full spider-man no way home trailer
that'll be coming in the next couple of months
but number two per the foreshadowing and all the
teasers wanda will probably get her full-blown
new comic book costume that she saw in her mind
stone vision that was meant to be a vision of
her future that it was giving her but she'll
also have to say goodbye to billy and tommy
not forever though early prediction obviously
they'll do a version of the wicked and speed comic
book story where they do come back later but as
teenagers but these versions the little kids those
are the ones she'll have to say goodbye to just
like she had to say goodbye to them in the comics
it'll be a big cry fest very traumatic but
not nightmare level trauma like they're not
going to do the full-blown mephisto with them
melting into puddles right in front of her
eyes they actually kind of did a version of
that on rick and morty they're not going to
be that traumatic on Wandavision but they will
probably tease or set up the concept of them
returning and foreshadowing eventual young
avengers team up with the other members of
the team that they're introducing slowly on the
other disney plus series so right now these are
the ones we know about patriot is supposed to
show up on falcon and winter soldier he's the
grandson of the isaiah bradley version of captain
america the og african-american captain america
we already know all about haley steinfeld's kate
bishop hawkeye on the hawkeye series later this
year there's miss marvel coming later this year
we have cassie lang's stature character coming
to ant-man 3 quantum mania they've recast that
role she's going to be played by catherine newton
in the movie now they have america chavez's miss
america character debuting during doctor strange 2
she's been a member of the team in the past
probably riri williams iron heart instead of
iron lad after they do the iron heart and
armor war series and then they might wind
up introducing a version of hulkling during
the nick fury avengers secret invasion series
if you're not a big comic book reader hulkling
doesn't have gamma powers like bruce banner hulk
or jennifer walter shehulk he's actually the
prince of the scrolls he shapeshifts that's
why he's all huge and green but number one really
big one getting into mutants and x-men in the mcu
since Wandavision has been an mcu house of m story
it would be weird of them to roll so hard on that
without also doing the big capstone finale moment
of her no more mutants line or some reference to
that early prediction they'll have a twist on that
moment at some point in the finale that will help
explain how more mutants start popping up all over
earth in the future like marvel phase 4 marvel
phase 5. monica rambeau is the best test case
for this she passed through the hex barrier at
least three times and per darcy it mutated her dna
beyond recognition turned her into a completely
different person on a cellular level but the
catches i don't think they're going to be quite
as on the nose with how they explain that it'll
just be implied or darcy or sword people will
make references to lasting traces of background
cosmic radiation having quote unquote unknown
effects on vast portions of earth's population and
that'll just let you know like oh i bet you some
more mutants are going to show up in the next
four or five years but everyone post all your
predictions in the finale obviously there's still
so many other storylines that i didn't address
in this video so i'll try to cover all that stuff
in my finale videos in the bonus videos that i do
after the fact there is a special bonus episode
it's not episode 10. it's just a bonus episode
for a bunch of behind the scenes stuff that'll
air the week after the finale then the week after
that is when falcon in winter soldier episode
1 starts and all my videos for that will work
just like my Wandavision videos so leave all your
big questions in the comments below and i'll keep
doing the disney plus giveaway in all my marvel
disney plus videos click here for my Wandavision
episode 9 finale trailer in that post credits
scene and click here for my full Wandavision
episode 8 video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!